so yeah I am I live in Amsterdam I'm
originally from the US and I live there
with my husband and my two kids who came
with me today but they didn't really
think this is cool enough to sit in on
so I think they're running around
outside I've been doing web design
professionally for about 15 years and
I'm currently a senior designer at
booking.com where I do both design as
well as HTML and CSS one of the things
that's fun about working there is seeing
the rather creative photos and names
that some properties have chosen for
themselves for instance how would you
like to stay in wrong place and of
course you can stay in hell or heaven
depending on the type of person that you
are I guess
and finally there's Jesus this is my
favorite line from its property
description
that Jesus is a great guy
so these are just a few of the over
eight hundred and two thousand
properties providing booking with their
own content for us to display that
content then has to be translated into
42 languages as does all the other
website content and the prices that you
see on this site are in one of fifty
four currencies with this huge variation
and content I have to make sure that my
designs can be incredibly flexible for
instance if I have to design a component
that includes the name of a property
that my name might be as short as two
characters or as long as 109 characters
or anywhere in between
so my component has to be flexible
enough to hold all the variations in an
elegant way in responsive web design the
challenge is that you never know how
much space is available outside the
component here the problem is kind of
the opposite not knowing how much stuff
is available inside the component but in
both cases the question is the same how
big do I make this thing so that
everything will fit nicely in responsive
web design you answer this question by
picking a percentage and mrm value or a
viewport unit based on what will work
well for that item and the others on the
page the majority of the time and these
are all good relative units of
measurement but they're not perfect they
are still a decision that you are making
ahead of time rather than a calculation
made on the fly for an individual users
precise set of viewing conditions and
the precise piece of content that
they're viewing at that moment they're
always going to be your best guess at
what will work well for the majority but
not necessarily the ideal for any one
thing in particular now don't get me
wrong I have nothing against using these
units of measurement of course they are
the units that I have chosen to use in
my work whenever possible for the last
10 years and I continue to use them but
any imposed unit of measurement is
always going to be an approximation of
the ideal flexbox is not the ideal
either it's a tool with strengths and
limitations just like any other but it
gets us closer to the ideal because with
it we know
have to set explicit dimensions at all
we can let the browser figure out what
size is best based on the space
available the surrounding elements and
the content within and we still get to
tell the browser a starting size a
starting point for that size to give it
some guidance but we're not laying down
a law as we are with explicit dimensions
even relative ones let me give you an
example of the difference between the
two approaches here is the job search
form from The Guardian site it's a
responsive layout they give all the
fields percentage widths including the
Select menu and the button and they
change those percentages at different
breakpoints this is the widest version
of the layout and they didn't use
flexbox and on it as they do now for
their main site they still use floating
here so I decided to make a copy of it
to see if I could improve it at all by
adding flexbox just as an exercise for
me not because there's anything bad
without their doing it currently so I
copied it this is my copy it uses floats
and percentage wits as they do and I use
this as my starting point and I then
tried to see if there was anywhere where
I could add flexbox to make the form
more responsive and I found two
opportunities for simple progressive
enhancement the first issue is that
because the Select menu is set to a
percentage not its content length the
menu text can sometimes be cut off also
the button can grow much wider than its
text which looks rather awkward in my
opinion even if you like it like that
the which is fine the point is that you
can't control it
the viewport is controlling it and
sometimes it will be snug to its text
and sometimes not
the percentage sizing becomes kind of
arbitrary this is the problem with
explicit dimensions now I could fix it
by tweaking the breakpoints and not
changing the layout until I'm sure that
the Select menu content can fit but this
is unreliable you can't always create a
whole new set of breakpoints to
accommodate one piece of content on one
page out of your whole site also it's
dependent on all users having the same
font size and on the content in that
select menu never changing neither of
which I think are safe assumptions
this is the perfect case for flexbox
because as I said it lets you avoid
explicit dimensions and use the Flex
property instead to control sizing this
tells the browser the starting size that
you want to use including the native
content size and whether the item can
grow bigger or smaller then the size to
fit the space available so for the
select menu and the button I want them
to stay at their content width exactly
not get bigger or smaller so I don't
want them to flex with the text fields I
want them to stretch to take up whatever
space is left after the select the
button and all the margins have been
accounted for
and I don't have to do any math to
figure out what value this should be I
just tell them to flex and let the
browser figure out the math so I can
also at the same time that I do this
keep the percentage widths in place for
non supporting browsers and add these
flex values on top as an enhancement the
second problem with the original that I
wanted to fix is that there's a slight
misalignment of the fields across the
line even though I set the same padding
on all of them this shows two different
browsers again I could fix this by
adjusting all the padding's
but it is browser dependent so it's
really annoying hard to get perfect a
more reliable and easier fix is to just
turn on flexbox for each field wrapper
because flex items across a row are
equal height by default so with its
wrapper a Flex container each field will
stretch to match the tallest one on its
line so these two lines of CSS in pink
fix the height mismatch in five seconds
and actually you can write it as one
line because you can leave the second
off it's the default value so although
the visual effect isn't huge in this
case neither is the effort to polish up
this form none of the Flex box changes
that I made to the form have to be
hidden from older browsers they simply
override existing properties and
browsers that understand them which
makes it really easy to progressively
enhance this form ie 9 and earlier we'll
see the top version which looks a bit
different but it's still usable and just
about everyone else will see the bottom
version I think this enhancement is
worthwhile to add because even though
the Flex box form does use the same
break points as the floater
original the fields inside are more
responsive to their content so overall
the layout of the fields looks more
proportional inside each of these
breakpoints content-driven breakpoints
are better than device size breakpoints
but they are still a decision that
you're making based on what is best for
hopefully the majority of your content
but not every component or piece of
content on every page at every moment
flexbox can enhance your components to
be more responsive within your
breakpoints the job forum was just a
demo but we do use flexbox in a similar
way live at booking comm on our customer
service forum which uses a fluid
responsive layout using flex the fields
fill the full width of their container
no matter its size switching from
stacked to 2x2 automatically as soon as
they can fit beside each other and by
automatically I mean no media queries
this is all of the CSS that's needed to
create those two layouts there's no
media queries because the browser
figures out the breakpoint for you using
flexbox the Flex property again is
simply an enhancement on top of the
floating and the percentage with that
control the layout of the form when Flex
box isn't available so the starter non
flex box version of the form layout seen
in IE seven through nine it has the same
two layouts
they just don't stretch to be full width
but I think that this small difference
is an acceptable trade-off for being
able to write just a few lines of CSS no
media queries and being completely done
with laying out an entire responsive
form let me walk you through how the CSS
works so first we turn on flex box using
display flex on the container that turns
the form into a Flex container and the
child fields into Flex items by default
this puts the items horizontally on a
single row but flex wrap wrap allows
them to wrap onto multiple rows as
needed so if I didn't have flex wrap
wrap set the fields would always say on
run one row no matter what even if
content has to be cut off or they
overflow out of their container
but with flexwrap they will be stacked
on narrow screens and then automatically
switched to side-by-side when there's
room for them to fit it's similar to
changing flex direction from column to
row and a media query but without
needing any media query so the
breakpoint can happen automatically in a
more natural spot with less CSS so the
fields do say row orientation the whole
time it's just that they may form up to
four rows when the viewport is narrow
which then looks like one column so then
the question is what makes them decide
to wrap the browser wraps them when it
can't fit them on one line but how does
it know they can't fit at a certain
point this is where their flex values
come in so let me define the Flex
property first before explaining this
particular value of the property so the
Flex property is set on Flex items to
assign them a proportional size it
affects either their width or their
height whichever is the main size and
that's the dimension along the main axis
so the main axis is simply the set by
Flex direction so flex Direction is set
to row my main axis is horizontal and
width is my main size if flex Direction
is set to column my main axis is
vertical and height is my main size and
there's up to three components to a flex
value as it's a shorthand property flex
grow means how much the Flex item will
grow relative to other items if there's
extra space available flex rank means
how much the item will shrink relative
to others if there's not enough space
and both flex grow and flex shrink are
set to unitless integers like zero one
two since they are specifying a
proportion not an absolute value it's
like the number of shares of extra space
that they get Flex basis is the initial
starting dimension before free space is
added on or taken away from the item and
it's set to any standard with their
height value including Auto which
basically sizes the item according to
its content for example on the
booking.com customer service form flex
basis is set to 40% so that's the
starting point each field will be 40% of
the width
of its container and then the browser
looks at the Flex grow and flex shrink
values to decide whether to get bigger
or smaller than the Flex basis value
Flex shrink the second value set to zero
doesn't let the field shrink smaller
than 40 percent effectively this means
that the most we can ever have an align
together is two right because three or
four forty percent wide items are never
going to fit on a line together so
that's why the form only gets two into a
two by two layout at its widest flex
grow the first value set to one means
that each field will get one share of
any available extra width on a line and
this is what ensures that the form is
always full width because it tells each
field to stretch to take up whatever
space is left over after the 40 percent
flex basis and the pixel margin and
padding have been accounted for so
basically what happens is when the
viewport gets narrow the combination of
the percentage flex basis size and the
pixel margin and padding makes two
inputs add up to more than 100% which
forces them to wrap and stack the same
thing happens with the float version
this is not a new sort of layout
behavior but with the Flex value as an
enhancement the Flex grow piece of that
value flex grow set to one ensures that
when the wrap happens each field
stretches to fill the width perfectly
rather than remaining 40 percent wide
and again flex box overrides the
floating and the width values
automatically so the Flex property can
be added on to the same rule without
having to hide anything from non
supporting browsers so three extra lines
flex box CSS made this form much more
responsive to the space available and
all without having to use a media query
another place on booking.com
where we change the layout without a
media query is within the map info
windows that show when you click on a
marker I had the task to add a message
about the room price that you see being
almost sold out and the logical place to
put it soon to be next to the price
especially since there's often a big gap
there and this is what that would look
like the price and the message
are visually connected and the message
kind of leads you to the the
call-to-action button so I like this but
the problem is that there is not always
a big gap there rack rate pricing long
languages long currencies can all take
up a lot of space in this case this is
due to variable content but the same
issue applies in responsive web design
of course where the width that you have
available in varies that you have
something sorry the width that you have
available to put something in varies as
the viewport width changes size so in
both cases I have the problem of wanting
to put something in a spot but not being
sure if that spot is always big enough
what I would like to happen is that the
text sits beside the price if there's
enough room and then when the space
shrinks below some minimum width that I
set it drops down onto the following
line and then it stretches to take up
the full width now without an explicit
width on the availability message the
red text making it float or inline block
will not let its text wrap so this first
image with the red text wrapping could
not happen the text would want to stay
all in one line and so it would always
drop below the price table cell will at
the text wrap within that area but it
won't let the entire block wrap down
below the price when there's not enough
room or when the space is just too
narrow for that text to look good there
so this second image with the red text
below couldn't happen so that leaves
Flex box which is kind of like the best
of both worlds and lets me have both of
these languages with one piece of CSS or
both of these layouts with one you know
piece of CSS so I get the stretch and
squish behavior of table cell but it
lets the boxes wrap if if I tell it to
and if it needs to based on the space
available and again it does this without
media queries so IE 7 8 & 9 users will
simply see the availab available 'ti
message always below the price which
doesn't look bad or broken the few line
of lines of flexbox code are then
layered on top as an enhancement for the
vast majority of users and flex box is
great
for this sort of micro layout stuff
managing the sizing and spacing of items
within a component or module you can use
flex locks in a similar way and
responsive designs where you have a
component that sometimes has room for
its sub items to sit side by side and
sometimes needs them to stack without
you having to figure out at what point
that happens another example of how flex
box can handle wrapping more elegantly
is in what we call the mini info windows
on our maps that show when you hover
over a marker I use flexbox to layout
the review score and the price on
opposite sides of the same line again I
couldn't give either of these two blocks
a width even in a relative unit of
measurement because the length of the
content in each can vary wildly without
set widths inline-block would not move
the price the price block to the right
side so that was out table-cell worked
fine without set widths but if the
content was long the two pieces could
overlap instead of the second block
wrapping to new line which would be
completely unacceptable
that left floating and flexbox as my
layout options floating worked but when
the content was long and the price
wrapped to a second line as in this
screenshot down here with the long
German words it would stay right aligned
which looks awkward so I decided to use
both float for older browsers and then I
overrode it with Flex box which lets the
text wrap to the left edge more
elegantly I didn't have to use modernizr
and hide pieces of CSS from certain
browsers flexbox just takes over if the
browser understands it so no matter what
the two blocks will appear side by side
in all browsers and they will wrap when
needed the wrapping and alignment of the
text just isn't quite as nice looking
and non flexbox browsers but that was
going to happen whether or not I added
flex box here I made a demo to show you
how this improved wrapping behavior can
come in handy on responsive sites
specifically this article header uses
flex box as an enhancement on top of
display:table-cell
to layout an align its various chunks of
con
and it switches the layout automatically
without a media query this header block
is basically a media block UI pattern
that you see everywhere right with an
image plus a block of text associated
with it except here the text portion
stretches to fill the whole width and
the whole height available thanks to
flex on the category the green block and
align content on the multiple rows using
flex to push the date to the opposite
side is a great enhancement for what
happens when there's not enough room to
fit both the category and the date on
the same line such as when the viewport
is very narrow or the content is very
long or both there's lots of ways to
align content to opposite sides of a
line with the old existing CSS that
we've had forever but if I used floating
or text the line to push the date to the
right side when the day needed to wrap
it would wrap down to the right edge
just like in the mini info windows on
the maps which looks kind of weird using
flex instead it wraps to the left side
which looks a lot more natural this is
not the only alignment enhancement that
flexbox can accomplish that no other CSS
can produce I briefly showed you the
line content property on this this
header but there are two other flex box
alignment properties that allow you to
align content in new ways really simply
which is invaluable and responsive
designs where the content wraps
differently at different viewport widths
for instance flexbox can distribute an
unknown number of items across an
unknown an area of unknown width or
height such as making a navbar full
width with equal spaces in between all
of the links if you wanted to make a
navbar like this you'd probably first
turn to display:table-cell and you would
be able to make the nav full width and
have the first and last links at the
edges and you could even make each of
the link boxes equal in width to each
other if used table layout fixed but you
would discover that you could not get
equal spaces between the text block of
each link so if I do display table and
table layout fixed on a ul
makes each Li the same width so they
look equally spaced if they have
backgrounds or borders but remove the
backgrounds and borders and you see that
the gaps actual the gaps between the
actual links text is not equal so longer
links have smaller spaces around them
short links have bigger spaces but
flexbox can fix these unequal gaps
really simply here is a simple navbar
from my flexbox demo site smores data us
for the starter layout i used inline
block to Center the links in a row under
the logo they don't stretch full width
but there's nothing broken or wrong
looking and it works as a layout in the
responsive page but there's no reason
why I can't add a few lines of flexbox
on top of this CSS to enhance the
responsiveness of the nav further I
simply added these two lines of flexbox
in pink to the existing rules the Li are
still set to inline block but now their
Flex items too so I can take advantage
of these new alignment properties within
flexbox such as justify content setting
justify content to space between moves
the first and last Li to the edges and
it equally distributes the space
remaining in between the other links so
using justify content space between here
is how the nav then looks on medium
width screens the links stretch out in
the Flex box version and they remain
centered in the non flex box browsers
now having the nav filling the full
width looks great on medium width
screens like this but on really wide
screens it starts looking too stretched
out I wanted to make it more responsive
to this extra space so I decided to use
flexbox to pin the first two links to
the left side of the logo and the last
two links to the right side of the logo
again a pretty common responsive nav
layout to do this I first added a media
query for wide screens so you do
sometimes need to still use media
queries with flexbox
and I also edit a link to the moderniser
script because I need to feed some
styles to only flexbox browsers in this
particular case as you'll see in just a
minute
much of the time flex locks and fallback
styles can coexist as they did with the
medium width version of the navbar that
I just showed you but occasionally
they'll conflict and you'll only want to
apply a certain property if Flex box is
in effect or not the modernize our
script is perfect for this it can detect
whether the browser does or doesn't
support Flex box and whether it supports
an old version or the current version
and then adds the appropriate classes to
your HTML tag which you can use to scope
the rules in your CSS if you don't like
moderniser and you want to keep the
feature detection in your CSS you can
also use the @ supports rule to detect
whether the browser supports Lex box and
feed rules only in that case to do
something like this so at supports and
moderniser are both good options for
those rare cases when you do need to
isolate your flex box styles from your
other CSS for my navbar here
I used modernizers flex box class to
scope this new rule to only flex flex
browsers where I want the nav to move up
on the to the same line as the logo non
supporting browsers will not use this
rule so they will still get the inline
block centered nav beneath the logo only
the Flex box version of the nav will
move up now to move the last two links
to the right side I simply set
margin-left:auto on the third link the
throw party link again scoped to only
flex box browsers and the reason that
this works is that in Flex box if you
set a margin and the main access to auto
it takes up all of the free space that's
left in that line so with
margin-left:auto on the throw a party
link the browser places all of extra
space in the line to its left side
effectively pushing it and all the stuff
after it to the right edge so I get that
parents of a split list without having
to cheat and break it into two lists in
the HTML which is less accessible and
robust not so good for responsive web
design where I'm trying to keep my HTML
the same at all viewport widths this is
a simple navbar but thanks to a bit of
flex box it can
make full use of the changing width
flexbox increases its responsiveness as
an enhancement where available flex box
is not only a great way to make better
use of the changing widths in a
responsive layout but also to make
better use of the changing heights so as
the viewport changes with your content
wraps differently so you can't count on
constant Heights for your content blocks
flex box can enhance the appearance of
this variable height because it works in
any direction so let's say that I want
to show some social media sharing icons
down the side of each article or media
object and that media object content
varies as does the viewport width which
controls wrapping so the height of each
varies and if I want to equally spaced
the icons vertically to take up the full
height I am out of luck
I cannot explicitly set each of them to
height 33% because the parent media
object has no explicitly set height
itself to base these percentages off of
so percentage height value does nothing
here but I don't need the height
property with Flex box first I make the
icon section and the content section
Flex items with the default horizontal
row alignment and I do this because I
need them to be equal height and sibling
flex items are equal height by default
thanks to the line items properties set
to stretch by default you can't see it
here because the icons are still top
aligned within their section but if the
two sections had background colors you
would see that icon section stretches to
match the height of the content section
so now the icon and the content section
are equal height flex items but the
individual icon images are not flex
items because only children of a Flex
container become Flex items not all
descendants but something can be able to
flex item and a Flex container so that's
what I do I turn the icons section into
a Flex container that makes its three
children icon images into Flex items but
this time I set Flex direction to column
to stack them vertically from top
to bottom this doesn't change anything
visually yet they already resect
vertically but remember that flex
direction also controls the main axis
with flex direction column the icons
main axis is now vertical so if I use
justify content space between two it
will equally spaced them over the main
axis which is the height no matter how
tall that is and here's the results each
media object has a different height but
the icons always span the full height
with equal spaces in between to make
this work with non flexbox browsers you
can use whatever technique you normally
would to get the icon block to sit next
to the content block such as
display:table-cell
or floating both of these can work and
exist with Flex Vox and the same CSS
rules floating I mean flexbox just
overrides the float and table properties
and browsers that understand it and then
non supporting browsers your the icons
will be either top aligned with the text
or vertically centered as a block the
browsers that don't support flex box
have about 5% global market share so a
few users will see the non flex box
versions that I've shown you in these
examples but none of those versions look
wrong or broken just a little different
which is already happening all the time
anyway flex box is simply an enhancement
to make better use of the space
especially between your breakpoints it's
not a true grid system it wasn't
designed to be so it's not the best
choice for your overall page layout but
it is a great choice for intelligently
sizing and aligning components and
smaller chunks of content within the
major page page sections flex box also
lets you visually rearrange content
which comes in handy again on responsive
sites where you're stuck with the same
HTML order at all the sizes but you want
to shuffle content around on different
views and it's sometimes hard to make a
block go where you want it to when
you're tied to a certain source order
but flex box makes this easier so
remember the split navbar I used
relative positioning and a negative
top value to move the navbar up
overlapping the same line as the logo
which is fine but since the logo is not
actually in the middle of the list the
links on either side of it can overlap
it if the browser window gets too small
I avoid this with a media query but if
the logo was actually moved in the flow
to the middle of the list I wouldn't
have to do this but I don't want to move
the logo in the middle of the list in
the HTML because on narrow screens I
still want it to come before the nav
with Flex box I can keep the logo in
before the links in the HTML but move it
visually and in the flow to the middle
using the order property you set the
order property on Flex items to specify
which order you want the browser to lay
them out in their container regardless
of the HTML order and the browser runs
from the lowest numbers including
negative to the highest so you can think
of it like assigning the items a
position number in a line the first two
links I want to stay first so they need
the lowest order value so I'll just
leave them with the default of zero the
logo I want to be next so it needs the
next highest order value I gave it one
the last two links need to come after
the logo so they need the next highest
order value I gave them too so now that
the logo is part of the line not
separate from it it won't work to just
have margin-left:auto on that third link
as before because with every last bit of
extra space in the line put to its left
it will squish the logo over on the
right side to fix this I can use two
auto margins and the browser will simply
divide the extra space on the line
evenly between the two items with those
margins so throw a party already has
margin-left:auto from before but I'll
sorry
I'll add the same to the logo so half
the extra space goes on the left side of
the logo half of it goes on the left
side of the throw a party link and thus
the logos move to the center now in
order to make this work I had to move
the logo from outside the UL to inside
at the same level as the other links
that's because order
only works on siblings within the same
Flex container you cannot move elements
outside of their container to be before
after stuff that's outside the container
this does make it limiting you have more
sorcery order independence than
currently out methods but you still have
complete freedom to move anything
anywhere this is perhaps a good thing
because you don't want to go crazy
moving everything around with the order
property when you reorder content with
Flex box you are only reordering it
visually it does not change the screen
reading order or the tab order so if the
content that you're reordering contains
text or tablet content make sure that
the HTML order is logical first and then
use visual reordering only if it's just
decorative and doesn't change the
meaning of the content I'm running out
of time but let me quickly give you a
simple example of accessible reordering
with Flex box so on this recipe the
photo comes before the ingredients list
in the HTML so that on the wider view I
can float it beside the ingredients and
the narrow mobile view just stacks
everything in the default HTML order but
I could use the Flex box order property
to move the photo from its HTML position
before the ingredients to above the rest
of title on mobile only and in this case
this is not going to cause accessibility
problems because there's no links in the
photo to tab 2 and there's no text in
the photo to be read by screen readers
because I would give it no lul text
because the recipe itself provides a
text alternative so to move the photo
and the styles outside any media queries
I set flex direction to column to stack
everything and I set the order value of
the image to negative 1 all the other
Flex items inside the recipe container
have the default order value of 0 so
negative 1 we'll move it to the top of
the stack and then on the desktop view I
simply turn off flex box by setting the
recipes display back to block that puts
the image back in the normal flow order
where I can then float it to the right
so there's no concern about flex box
support on desktop since I'm not using
it there and any mobile browsers that
don't support it will simply see the
image before the ingredients as
normale I already showed you the
Guardians job search form which doesn't
use flexbox but their main site now does
and they use flexbox to shuffle the
stories around when you get to the wide
view they actually don't use the order
property to do this the Flex box lets
you run content not just top to bottom
and left to right but also bottom to top
and right to left so this is another
clever way that flexbox can improve
responsiveness so definitely go to their
site and check out their CSS to learn
more about the they're sort of
reordering I've shown you code for most
of these examples but I don't think that
the code is the most important part of
learning flexbox I think the biggest
obstacle to getting started with it is
not being able to picture how to use it
because you're stuck thinking in terms
of what was possible with floats and
other old layout methods it was the same
when we switched from tables to CSS and
from fixed to fluid you had to make a
mental shift to start thinking in terms
of the new possibilities and approaches
to old problems flexbox lets you do lots
of things that you haven't been able to
do before and lots of things that you
could do before but now in an even
simpler way once you see what flexbox
can do in the real world you can start
picturing how to use it in your own work
to solve real responsive web design
problems today flex box can be tricky to
wrap your head around at first but once
you've learned it it's an incredibly
quick cheap way for you to add more
responsiveness to your components and it
may sound weird to talk about enhancing
responsiveness but I don't think that
responsive web design is either on or
off either your site is responsive or
it's not there's always more that you
could do to make a responsive site even
more responsive to the different user
settings and the content within it flex
box is one of those things that you can
do as I hope you have seen with these
examples don't be afraid to add flex box
to your work because flex box is not all
or nothing you you don't need to use it
you don't need to use every single part
of it to layout every single
on your site you can keep using floats
or table display or whatever it is you
use to create layouts just add on flex
box in one spot to add one little
enhancement and see how it can improve
responsiveness on your site
thanks very much